Let's try once more.
I'm going to give him one other opportunity.
Diego from Mexico is back.
I don't know what happened the first time.
Diego, are you with us?
Yes.
Can you hear me?
I can hear you.
Yes.
Oh, thank you.
I thought my I.D. card didn't work.
It works beautifully.
Well, it's The David Pakman Show this.
My question is about this.
Are the stock market and the recent plunge
because Yahoo!
News that Trump is going to Harvard, well
halted all negotiations like I can't understand
what's the political players here like?
I don't.
Why there is one.
No, I think I think he's I think he's on.
I think he's on roid rage from the dexamethasone.
It makes no sense.
And, you know, the thing was when when this
all happened on Tuesday, first Trump tweets
no second stimulus and the stock market crashes,
then the stock market closes.
And at night, Donald Trump tweets, If they
get me a bill to sign to send 12 hundred dollar
checks to people, I'll sign it and we'll send
the checks.
And then Wednesday, the stock market goes
up for 400 points intraday.
I don't know that Donald Trump, you know,
in general, I question how stable Donald Trump
is mentally.
Right now, he seems particularly unstable
and it may be because of the medications he's
on.
But you're completely right.
Sending checks to people is the law.
It's the Hail Mary.
It's the last chance Trump has to try to win
some votes back.
Why would he abandon it?
It makes no sense.
Exactly.
Even right.
Right.
Leaving Paul Rasmussen has him down, I believe.
Twelve points.
Yeah.
And the only explanation I've heard of is
that he's taken the country hostage and saying,
if I don't win, you can't even get the stimulus
right because of the lame duck period.
So even then, you will have to wait.
The only way you can get relief soon is if
you vote for me.
But I don't know.
Well, the crazy thing about this is that although
it's true that if Biden wins, Trump probably
won't do any stimulus during the lame duck
just to spite people in the long run.
Right.
Biden is likely to, in total, do something
better for the average person than whatever
Trump is dangling now.
So it's not it's a threat.
And of course, people will have to figure
out what to do for the next four months.
But in the longer term, if Biden does win,
people will be much better off.
Exactly.
I can even I can't even see it from Trump's
side, but it makes no sense.
Yeah.
Well, thank you for taking my call.
Saludos is in Mexico.
All right.
Very much saludos and appreciate the call.
Hope to speak to you soon.
That's Diego from Mexico.